[Music]
not only did you win but also the show
is coming back for season two describe
the feeling right now for both of you
guys
god it's great you saying but right now
it's about the new star being born
she deserved the win she fought for a
life I'm excited to work with her and
she was incredible I was watching the
show today I got goose bumps and she
took that crown that that trophy she the
Queen and she she she a new star I mean
like hearing him say all these
incredible things about you I just I
feel on there I mean because CDJ Kelly
and honestly I wake up and I just you
know I feel like I live for moments like
this and the fact that it's happening at
the age of 20 it's like God just really
made away from me and there ain't no way
I can fight against this wheel I'm
hungry I'm hungry
we got that tonight there's so many
competition shows out there but we've
made an artist how do you ensure that
she becomes a superstar I'm gonna be
honest with you all you could do in this
game is really tell you a truth we've
both been blessed with that intuition on
how to find talent and no one has
something special in the room and I
think she's a total package and you know
I'm gonna push it of greatness and
Khalid is gonna push it of greatness and
Khalid that he makes nothing but hits
these until you guys both be back yeah I
mean I mean Bach said that they wanted
to make us the highest-paid on
television so I guess they gave us the
offer we couldn't refuse Billy a pity
Rock
yeah no doubt we went we also want to
thank on Katy Perry you know saying for
that for that check that you guys
setting the bar yeah